foreign
is in Greenville South Carolina hi
Jordan welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi
um I owe eleven thousand dollars on a
car that doesn't run and I can't afford
to fix it and I really don't know what
to do
ouch
why can't you afford to fix it
um
follow-up question
why don't you have any money
well I am working
um it's just a car that I got back in
high school and my parents were getting
me in the car but
um
I'm having to pay for it and
um How much would it cost to fix
ten thousand dollars who said
um we've got lots of estimates around my
area and it's been to multiple body
shops
um oh so you got you got in a wreck and
didn't have insurance
no um
basically they've told me the the making
model
working anymore like they put a bad
piston in it and you don't go to a body
shop
that would be a mechanic not a body shop
all kinds of mechanics and people okay
so uh what do you get what do you make a
year
um monthly about 1500 to 1800 what do
you do
I'm an interior designer and a chef at a
fine dining restaurant
no you're a sous chef
yeah she's a sous chef yes chefs don't
make 1800. okay
um at fine dining anyway
um
so what are you 23
thank you
I'm sorry
22 22. okay good guess Dave like you've
done this before okay uh
and you have a roommate
or you live at home
um I was at home
so you don't have overhead
and you bring in I don't you bring in
1800 a month where does that money go
um I've been paying off my car with
[Music]
it I have about uh 4 500 saved up I'm I
just recently signed up for the
Financial Peace University and um I'm on
baby step two good for you but I still
owe eleven thousand I got yeah and
that's is that your only debt is your
car
um I have 1 000 in medical bills okay
good good
okay
and you're working a lot
yes and not making any money
no the life of a chef a sous chef okay
oh yeah and an assistant yeah yeah
um are you putting in more than 40 hours
um
I'm not I'm not sure because how are you
getting to work
um I'm borrowing my mom's car right now
because her and my stepdad work out the
same job okay
well it sounds like you've got a
wonderful support system
you've got a place to live
while you fight your way through this
and you've just got a a horrible car
situation you're being very smart you're
taking a class on how to handle money
very smart uh you've saved up forty five
hundred dollars very smart uh so the
weak spot in your story me looking in
from the outside is your income
you don't make any money
yeah
so
um your is your dream to be a fine
dining chef
no I went to school for interior design
and when I got out of school I um
instantly went into a design company
where I
am now the designers assistant but um
and that's your day job
yes and what do you make what do you
make at that
15 an hour this is the same amount but
that is
um under the table because
I'm just her assistant like she works by
herself
okay so two different areas of your life
we've got to work on your long-term play
is you need a path for interior design
that's not fifteen dollars part-time
under the table
I just um I did get my degree in
interior design okay great so you so
you're completely underpaid and
underemployed there and in addition to
that your other job is an underpaid job
as well just by the nature of what it is
uh and so uh what we've got to do is
we've got to get your day job cooking
better
better much better interior design day
job and a much better night job and Sous
Chef's not it because you need three
four thousand dollars a month coming in
and you can solve this problem real
quick
yeah but you're you're starving to death
yes so let's let's work on those two
sides of your career the go get a much
better part-time job than sous chef Sous
Chef's not your dream anyway it's hard
freaking work it's hot back there
yeah I mean it that's some of the
hardest thankless jobs the chef gets all
the credit and you do all the work
uh and most Sous chefs are Chef wannabes
and they're it's their dream to be a big
time Chef you don't even want to do that
and you're you say and so with that in
mind that job sucks completely passion
for it I know but you need to you need
to go do something where you make some
money kiddo that's right now raise your
sights in the interior design side of
things you've got a degree you've got
some experience you're very creative as
a sous chef all that creativity is what
you love but Dave's right you've got to
say I if I've got to go work for a
construction company and and and Stage
rooms I'm going to do that for a season
well there's nothing wrong with that
that's good money doing that's right why
because we want to get out of this
financial hole the good news is you're
off and running on the baby steps so
glad you're doing that but we're gonna
make the move right now to get stable in
the now and you're not in any way uh
forfeiting your dream of interior design
so that's the key you can always get
back to that but right now we've got to
get more money coming in that's going to
change everything for you yeah I want
you to go pick up three jobs a new
interior design job that's a thousand
times better than the one you got and
two part-time jobs that pay big money
and I want you to work all the time
and get you three four five thousand
dollars a month coming in and all of a
sudden this car issue will evaporate
and uh by the way I'm not buying that
you owe eleven thousand dollars on a car
that needs ten thousand dollars worth of
repairs I don't either I I'm just an old
redneck that turns wrenches and so don't
believe it I just don't believe it and
uh so I I think I think there's
something else to do here you may want
to junk the car and get what you can get
for it with a little bit of work but you
probably get three or four thousand
dollars for anything that's running
and uh and then just talk to the bank
about you paying the difference and then
work your way through that and go get
you a junker car a two three four
thousand dollar card to pay cash for
then start working your debts off but
you've got to work twice as much as
you're working at much better jobs
that's the solution to your situation
and I need to hear more of a roar in
your voice you you sound really really
really uh
like you're 16.
I want you to go ah
get after it kiddo you've got some
skills and all this stuff keeps
happening to you and I want you to rise
up and go happen to this stuff you've
got some you got some stuff you can go
do this I agree you know what here's a
practical example of that that Dave's
giving you here listen get your dad or
your uncle or friends that knows some
good old boy that's been working on cars
for longer than you've been alive times
three and have him look at it let's
really dive into this thing that's
taking some action yeah you got to
happen to these things you've kind of
accepted one job accepted another no and
you need to go get some stuff
and that's going to put you in this
situation you need incomes what you need
bad and you need a better solution on
the car than ten thousand dollars to fix
it
you know get it get it limping get it
sold get out from under it move on the
next thing get your three thousand
dollar car to drive this is the Ramsay
show